pas
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat après le vote
le 10 mai dernier par l'assemblée
nationale du projet de loi
constitutionnelle sur l'équilibré des
finances publiques
c'est au tour du sénat de se pencher sur
ce qu'on appelle la règle d'or qui est
censé accompagner le retour du déficit
public de 7% à 3 % du pib d'ici à 2013
les sénateurs auditionnent les ministres
michel mercier et françois baroin car je
vous rappelle que ce texte prévoit
d'inscrire dans la constitution le
principe de lois cadres qui programment
sur au moins trois ans les efforts que
la france doit fournir pour parvenir à
cet équilibre budgétaire ce texte sera
examiné en séance publique le 14 juin
prochain au sénat mais pour être adoptée
définitivement il faut passer par un
vote du parlement réuni en congrès à
versailles
mais pour l'heure aucune date n'a été
fixée tout de suite donc cette audition
très bonne fin d'après-midi à tous alors
mes chers collègues
donc je remercie bien sûr
monsieur le garde des sceaux et monsieur
le ministre du budget des comptes
publics de la fonction publique de la
réforme de l'état et porte parole du
gouvernement mais ça oui c'était
monsieur le garde des sceaux me la
justice et des libertés publiques ou
privées et libertés mes chers collègues
je les remercie donc de devenir est
exposé le projet de loi
constitutionnelle dont je vous rappelle
que c'est s'agissant d'une proposition
d'un projet de loi constitutionnelle
l'examen suit la procédure classique
sans établissement d'un texte de la
commission
la commission des lois examinera la
semaine prochaine le projet la
commission des finances et la commission
des affaires sociales la semaine du 7
juin
voilà pour vous donner un peu de
l'indication donc je vais donner
immédiatement la parole au ministre
monsieur le garde des sceaux
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame madame et monsieur le président
je veux par là même à dresser un budget
digne et georges jacques hyest est
aujourd'hui messieurs les rapporteurs
généraux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le sénat et plus
particulièrement les commissions des
finances des affaires sociales a
toujours eu à coeur de garantir
l'équilibré des finances publiques
et je peux en parler en connaissance de
cause pour avoir siégé de nombreuses
années au sein de la commission des
finances du sénat et savoir l'importance
que vous attachez l équilibre budgétaire
et pour citer suffit de marigny nous ne
pouvons plus cautionner selon son
expression
la soutenable légèreté de la dette
depuis trente ans les déficits
s'accumulent et l'endettement s'accroît
en outre la crise économique et
financière sans précédent qu'a connu
l'économie mondiale entre 2008 et 2010
hassoumi l'ensemble des pays développés
à des tensions inédite sur financement
de la dette souveraine
c'est dans ce contexte qu'en 2009 vous
appelez de vos voeux des décisions
fortes pour réduire les dépenses à
préserver les recettes souligné en
particulier que des règles de bonne
gouvernance des finances publiques était
à inventer dans sa très récente étude
économique sur la france
le cd a reconnu la pertinence de la
trajectoire d'assainissement prévus par
le gouvernement
jusqu'en 2014 trajectoire dont
d'ailleurs est les derniers chiffres
connus montre la soutenabilité et la
cohérence mais le cd1 a aussi souligné
que la france aurait intérêt à se doter
d'un cadre budgétaire renforcée à valeur
constitutionnelle pour donner toute
autorité nécessaire à l'accomplissement
de ses objectifs
et c'est ce que vous propose le
gouvernement avec le projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui sera très
prochainement souvient votre examen
comme via aide à le rappeler le
président jean jacques hyest la révision
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008
avait déjà posé quelques jalons
prévoyait notamment à l'article 34 de la
constitution que les orientations
pluriannuelles des finances publiques
serait défini par des lois de
programmation s'inscrivent dans
l'objectif d'équilibré des comptes des
administrations publiques
avec le projet de loi le gouvernement
vous propose de franchir une étape
supplémentaire en inscrivant dans la
constitution le principe et les
modalités institutionnelles d'un retour
durable à l'équilibré des finances
publiques
en effet la constitution ne se limite
pas à organiser le fonctionnement de nos
institutions
elle est aussi l'expression du pacte
social qui unit chacune et chacun
d'entre nous autour d'un projet commun
vivre ensemble c'est adopter un
comportement responsable vis-à-vis des
générations futures afin de ne pas
obérer l'avenir
être responsable c'est infini avec le
creusement des déficits et de
l'endettement public
nous ne pouvons reporter à plus tard les
choix qui s'imposent à notre génération
et compromettent ainsi la liberté de
choix et la dépendance financière et
économique des générations suivantes
ces risques ne sont en rien hypothétique
comme chacun ici le sait plusieurs pays
européens y ont été durement confrontée
contraint de faire appel à l'aide
internationale et l'actualité même
aujourd'hui se rappelle tout à fait à
nos souvenirs
ce révélateur brutal nous a renforcés
dans la conviction qu'il faut
intensifier nos efforts pour une
meilleure gouvernance des finances
publiques a fait que seul approfondie
qui a mené à cette fin le gouvernement
depuis plus d'un an avec les expertises
de messieurs chômeurs et cotisent et de
monsieur camdessus nous a permis
d'aboutir au projet qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui dans le seul examen par
l'essor de l'assemblée nationale a
apporté plusieurs modifications projet
de loi tout en souscrivant très
largement à sa finalité et à la
pertinence de la démarche celle ci
suppose la mobilisation tant du
gouvernement qui prépare le budget elle
exécute que du parlement qu'il le vote
et le contrôle les grands axes du projet
ont ainsi pu être précisé qu'il s'agit
du monopole des lois de finances et de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
matière fiscale des nouvelles lois
cadres d'équilibré des finances
publiques ou de l'information du
parlement sur le pacte de stabilité et
mon collègue et ami françois barois
reviendra très naturellement plus au
mouvement et plus en détail sur
l'ensemble de ces questions
je voudrais simplement évoqué les
grandes lignes du dispositif tel qui
vous est soumis aujourd'hui
tout d'abord le premier objectif du
texte est simple il s'agit de réserver
les dispositions relatives aux
prélèvements fiscaux et recettes
sociales aux lois de finances et de
financement de sécurité sociale
le projet de loi modifie l'article 34 de
la constitution pour éviter la
dispersion de dispositions fiscales et
sociales dans l'ensemble des textes
législatifs dispersion qui nuit à la
cohérence globale de stratégie de
prélèvements obligatoires
ce dispositif instaure donc une
responsabilité commune du gouvernement
et du parlement sur les niches fiscales
ou sociales 1,6
les parlementaires qui souhaiteront de
nouveaux prélèvements obligatoires
pourront le proposer par voie
d'amendement à la loi de finances ou de
financement de la sécurité sociale le
gouvernement quant à lui ne pourra plus
prendre notamment par voie d'ordonnancé
par exemple des mesures relatives à la
fiscalité ou aux ressources de la
sécurité sociale
l'assemblée nationale a approuvé le
principe du monopole des lois
financières pour créer des prélèvements
obligatoires mais en s'inspirant quant
aux modalités de contrôle de cette règle
de nouvelles du dispositif prévu à
l'article 41 de la constitution
s'agissant 1 cette fois ci de la
frontière entre la loi et le règlement
ainsi le dépôt de propositions de loi ou
d'amendements constitue contenant pardon
les dispositions fiscales ou relatives à
d'autres ressources de la sécurité
sociale restera possible mais le
gouvernement ou le président de
l'assemblée concernée aura désormais non
pas certes l'obligation mais la faculté
à tout moment de la procédure
législative d'opposer une irrecevabilité
en cas de désaccord c'est au conseil
constitutionnel qu'il reviendrait de
trancher le différend
sachant que lorsqu'il sera saisie sur le
fondement de l'article 61 de la
constitution le conseil constitutionnel
aura le pouvoir et même le devoir de
censurer et les dispositions en cause et
ceci alors même que l'irrecevabilité
n'aurait pas été soulevée dans les
débats j'ai le sentiment mesdames et
messieurs c'est d'atr que le compromis a
ainsi élaboré répond à l'ensemble des
préoccupations exprimées jusqu'à l'heure
sur la question de ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler le monopole fiscal
la seconde mesure phare du projet est
relative à la création des lois cadres
d'équilibré des finances publiques
ce nouvel instrument juridique est l'une
des innovations majeures du texte des
lois-cadres on a du raid appliquée dans
la durée d'application était fixé à au
moins trois ans par l'assemblée
nationale fixeront pour chaque année un
objectif constitué d'un maximum de
dépenses d'un minimum de recettes qui
s'imposeront annuellement aux lois de
finances et au loi de financement de
sécurité sociale
à l'initiative de l'assemblée nationale
le texte prévoit expressément une
obligation de rattrapage
les écarts constatés lors de l'exécution
des lois de finances et de l'application
des lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale devront être compensées d'une
année sur l'autre grâce à ce cadre
budgétaire renforcée de valeur
constitutionnelle
nous donnerons les moyens de réaliser
l'objectif d'équilibré des comptes
publics
les députés ont également précisé que
comme il est naturel
la loi-cadre pourraient être modifiées
en cours d'exécution afin de pouvoir
s'adapter à l'évolution de la
conjoncture économique
c'est ce que la france a dû faire lors
de la récente crise pour mettre en
oeuvre le plan de relance cette
flexibilité doit cependant être très
clairement encadrée pour garder tout son
sens à la programmation et préserver
ainsi l'objectif de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire
l'assemblée nationale a donc prévu que
les modalités de modification des lois
cadres soit inscrite dans la loi
organique
j'appelle est votre attention sur le
fait que cette solution doit être
examinée beaucoup de soin pour ne pas
vider le principe de la loi cadre de sa
substance
deuxièmement l'assemblée nationale a
également souhaité que les lois de
finances et de financement de la
sécurité sociale soit désormais soumises
de plein droit au conseil
constitutionnel afin que celui ci puisse
examiner leur conformité à la loi cadre
qui elle même aura fait l'objet d'un
contrôle de plein droit
cette solution certes relativement
complexe car elle fera coexister pour
les lois financières annuelles à contre
systématique par rapport aux lois cadres
et un contrôle sur saisine par rapport
aux autres éléments du bloc de
constitutionnalité a toutefois le mérite
de garantir un contrôle constitutionnel
complet et d'assurer ainsi la parfaite
crédibilité du dispositif de retour à
l'équilibré et c'est là un des objectifs
essentiels du gouvernement
enfin le texte confère une valeur
constitutionnelle à l'information du
parlement
sur les orientations du programme de
stabilité européen
le texte prévoit en effet que le projet
de programme devra obligatoirement être
adressées aux assemblées avant sa
transmission aux institutions de l'union
européenne approuvent en est cette
logique
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité que le
parlement dispose d'au moins deux
semaines pour l'examiner a également que
compléter alors des mécanismes a fact
projet de programme de stabilité soit
systématiquement soumis à l'examen d'une
commission permanente et qu'à la demande
du gouvernement ou d'un groupe
parlementaire le projet puisse faire
l'objet d'un débat en séance suivie d'un
vote qui n'engagera pas la
responsabilité du gouvernement
cette approche souple et cohérente corée
pas carrément ou la cohérentes et
adaptées
mesdames et messieurs et les sénateurs
l'allemagne a écrit dans sa constitution
un calendrier de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire le gouvernement vous propose
certes une méthode différente mais la
finalité est la même
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de votre
assemblée de ce projet de loi comme
d'ailleurs nos efforts actuels n'est pas
un geste de circonstance monsieur que
l'on bat s inscrit dans une démarche de
long terme visant à garantir un autre
modèle social et notre souveraineté pour
les générations futures
tous nous sommes parfaitement conscients
que l'on ne peut plus obérer l'avenir en
vivant à crédit par le creusement des
déficits et tous j'en suis sûr
nous nous retrouverons sur les principes
qui sous-tendent le projet qui faisait
soubie et sur les mécanismes qui
l'institut je vous remercie
en ayant commis six ans est pas là
monsieur le garde mais je peux vous
donner un peu de mon temps de parole
pour que vous applaudissent il garde des
sceaux en amérique a pas de problème on
n'en voulait pas merci votre autorité
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois réprimant la commission des
finances madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales sur
rapporteur général monsieur roy pourtant
mais là messieurs les sénateurs
pardonnerez je serais probablement un
peu redondant au regard des propos de
présentation du garde mais c'est assez
logique je rentrerai juste dans deux ou
trois détails complémentaires et avec
michel mercier nous tenons à votre
disposition naturellement pour répondre
à vos questions
je rappelle évidemment que ce texte
marque une étape décisive dans un
processus qui est engagée comme l'a dit
le garde des sceaux depuis maintenant
plus d'un an et demi puisque à l'issue
de la première conférence sur le déficit
le présent la république avait voulu
rénover radicalement la gouvernance de
nos finances publiques c'est un constat
qui s'appuyait se fondait sur
l'évolution de l'endettement de la
france durant les trente dernières
années
le rapport champsaur et éco this
effectivement avait bien montré contre
78 en 2008 l'encours de la dette était
multiplié par 18 et évidemment ce
phénomène a été largement amplifié par
la réalité d'impact de la crise dans la
situation de nos finances publiques en
france comme d'ailleurs dans la plupart
des autres pays occidentaux et l'union
européenne il suffit de constater
l'actualité récente pour s'en convaincre
cette récession mondiale de 2008-2009
avec l'effet des stabilisateurs
automatiques en recettes on joue un rôle
non négligeable dans cette évolution
récente de l'endettement
mais ce que l'on peut noter au cours de
ces 30 dernières années c'est évidemment
l'insuffisante maîtrise de nos comptes
qui est à l'origine de la dérive dans
cette globalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle le chef de
l'état l'an dernier a exprimé le souhait
de voir l'ensemble des administrations
publiques se doter d'une règle
équilibre et il a demandé à cette époque
à michel camdessus de présider un groupe
de travail sur ce sujet dès l'été 2010
nous avons appliqué toutes les
recommandations la commission camdessus
qui pouvait l'être cadre constitutionnel
inchangé ça s'est traduit notamment par
le vote de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques cette botte cette loi
est en quelque sorte la préfiguration de
ce qui vous est proposé dans le texte
constitutionnel qui portera le nom de
lois cadres d'équilibré des finances
publiques
la loi de programmation je le rappelle
nous on mène sur des périodes triennales
glissante qui offre une faculté pour le
gouvernement de proposer au parlement
des objectifs intangibles en matière de
réduction des déficits est évidemment
une stabilité nos finances publiques en
agissant sur les différentes sources de
dépenses de l'état des collectivités
locales d'assurance-maladie fixant dans
la constitution changeant et des
nominations au plan loi cadre on donne
une dynamique forte et puissante et une
cohérence à la gestion dans le
calendrier d'échéances qui correspondent
à autant de rendez vous aussi bien du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du parlement que
de la france vis-à-vis de ses
partenaires européens
cela permettrait aussi de fixer dans le
cadre de cette programmation des
plafonds globaux par mission dépenses de
l'état ainsi que l'impact annuel minimal
de mesures nouvelles en recettes et nous
avons également adopté sous l'autorité
du premier ministre qui avait adressé
une circulaire
ces mesures qui sont évidemment aussi
contraignantes pour la représentation
nationale qu'elle doit l'être pour le
gouvernement et le gouvernement s'est
appliqué à lui même à travers la
circulaire de juin dernier les
dispositifs conférant le monopole des
mesures fiscales ou relative recettes
sociales à l'intérieur de la loi de
finances ou la loi de financement de
sécurité sociale
notre objectif sur ce point est à
présent de consolider définitivement ce
que nous considérons est ce que je crois
être une réalité pour touche des
avancées en les inscrivant dans notre
loi fondamentale sur les grands axes
sont redire ce cas
très bien dit michel mercier juste de
rappeler que le gouvernement propose
d'inscrire dans la constitution donc
trois séries de dispositions les
lois-cadres je n'y reviens pas je crois
que vous avez l'esprit nous avons
l'expérience avec les lois de
programmation
je veux juste souligner une fois encore
que ce sont des obligations aussi
importante pour l'exécutif et qui en
liaison avec le parlement devra aussi
prendre la mesure de l'impact budgétaire
de ces politiques publiques nous sommes
là aussi dans la cohérence de la
dernière révision notre loi fondamentale
j'ajoute que ces lois cadres d'équilibré
des finances publiques pourront être
soumises à un double contrôle du conseil
constitutionnel
d'une part avant leur adoption elles lui
seront systématiquement déferré et
d'autre part le conseil constitutionnel
vérifiera chaque année la conformité des
lois de finances et des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale à
l'effort programmé en loi-cadre toute
majorité désormais devra prendre ses
responsabilités et inscrire son action
en cohérence avec l'objectif de moyen
terme d' équilibre des finances
publiques qu'ils se seront assignés le
deuxième axe de la révision
constitutionnelle a pour objet d'éviter
la dispersion des dispositions fiscales
et sociales dans l'ensemble des textes
législatifs avant de détailler cet
aspect du projet je veux rappeler que le
gouvernement s'est imposé cette
discipline je le redis une nouvelle fois
notre trajectoire des mesures de
prélèvement obligatoire sera fixée ainsi
de manière impérative dans les lois card
et il nous apparaît naturellement
cohérent de vouloir centraliser
l'ensemble des mesures de nature fiscale
ou sociale
je me permets de rappeler que l'addition
des mesures dérogatoires au droit commun
en matière fiscale représente parlant
sous le contrôle du président de la
commission des finances et du rapporteur
général environ 75 milliards pour les
dispositifs dérogatoires de nature
sociale ça représente 45 milliards et
nous avons l'histoire récente de ces 25
30 dernières années sans montrer du
doigt tel ou tel gouvernement
l'expérience suffisamment acquise de
l'addition de mesures qu'on appelle
niches sociales ou fiscales dans des
textes choix sous l'impulsion du
gouvernement soit d'initiative
parlementaire
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui les moyens
quand la situation de nos finances
publiques d'aller plus loin dans
type de développement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je crois dans le respect
des dispositions des lois cadres
le travail sera facilité pour le
parlement dans son rôle de contrôle de
l'action gouvernementale et pour le
conseil constitutionnel dans les
nouvelles prérogatives qui lui sont
conférés cette nouvelle règle
contribuera aussi à limiter le
foisonnement de toutes ces niches qui
sont de source de complexité
d'incohérence de perte de recettes pour
l'état et c'est un point sur lequel
évidemment nous sommes très attentifs
nous voulons également mettre un terme
au mitage inexorable de ce système
fiscal
à ce titre l'inscription dans notre
constitution d'un monopole des lois de
finances et de financement de la
sécurité sociale nous semble essentiel
c'est vraiment un élément qui correspond
à une colonne vertébrale de ce vers quoi
le gouvernement veut tendre et aussi de
la nature profonde de la puissance des
engagements que la france prend
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires européens
nous souhaitons vraiment qu'une telle
disposition puisse voir le jour
nous donnerons naturellement soucieux de
respecter l'initiative parlementaire en
matière de recettes fiscales et sociales
il nous semble que la nouvelle rédaction
de l'article 34 que nous vous
proposerons n'apportera qu'une
instruction formelle en aucun cas
matériel à l'initiative parlementaire
des dispositions d'origine parlementaire
pourront toujours intervenir sur tout
sujet fiscal mais tout simplement pas à
tout moment par ailleurs dans le texte
qui vous est proposé il convient de
souligner que la présente révision vise
à faire du monopole un motif
d'inconstitutionnalité
c'est évidemment ça le sens de la
démarche de cette révision
constitutionnelle est pas nécessairement
d'irrecevabilité des propositions de loi
ou des amendements parlementaires
le dépôt des propositions de loi ou
d'amendements contenant des dispositions
fiscales ou sociales
concernant les recettes seraient donc
possible mais le gouvernement ou le
président de l'assemblée concernée
pourrait à tout moment de la procédure
législative soulever l'irrecevabilité
pour méconnaissance du même des lois de
finances et de financement de la
sécurité sociale nous avons donc opté au
cours du débat
en première lecture à l'assemblée pour
une application souple du monopole qui
consiste à admettre la mise en
discussion des articles et amendements
parlementaires à caractère fiscal la
charge incomberait ensuite au conseil
constitutionnel en cas de recours de
censuré les dispositions non conformes
ou nouvel article je le rappelle on
pourra toujours d'initiative
parlementaire examiner les mesures de
cette nature mais pas à tout moment et
comme vous savez que dans le calendrier
budgétaire
il est dans l'histoire récente et même
un peu passé d'usagé et presque
désormais d'habitude nous traiter de
projet de loi de finances rectificative
et nous allons d'ailleurs cette année
même inauguré le principe d'un projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificatif ou et qui sont des
rendez vous réguliers qui ne donne pas
un horizon trop lointain lorsqu'une
initiative parlementaire voudra aussi
s'engager sur le domaine de l' exception
fiscale ou de l'exemption sociale enfin
c'est le troisième axe de notre projet
de révision constitutionnelle nous
voulons inscrire dans la constitution le
principe d'une meilleure association du
parlement dans le cadre de la nouvelle
procédure dite du semestre européen
nous souhaitons là encore gravé dans le
marbre ce que nous avons fait à deux
reprises au début de l'été dernier il y
encore quelques semaines pour ce qui
concerne la transmission systématique
des programmes de stabilité au parlement
avant j'ai bien avant qu'ils ne soient
adressés à la commission européenne
je dois à la vérité de dire pour ceux
qui ont participé à nos travaux aussi
bien devant la rotation blake à
l'assemblée nationale que c'était de
qualité que le principe même de
l'engagement a aussi beaucoup de vertus
pour l'exécutif dans la force dont la
sincérité dans la puissance de la parole
engagée au titre de notre pays vis-à-vis
de ses partenaires
je vous le rappelle a encore la
constitutionnalisation de cette
troisième règle est un enfant un
engagement fort du gouvernement en
faveur du parlement c'est une avancée
indiscutable par rapport à la situation
antérieure
c'est aussi une avancée par rapport à
nos partenaires qui je le rappelle sont
encore très peu nombreux à prévoir une
évolution comparable de leur procédure
n'est pas douteux que le modèle français
servir de référence dans ce domaine
puisque le rendez vous du semestre
européen s'appliquera à tous les membres
de l'union il me semble qu'on inscrivant
une telle mesure dans notre constitution
le gouvernement veut marquer
l'importance qu'il accorde au rôle des
parlementaires dans la maîtrise et la
gouvernance des finances publiques de
notre pays
voilà monsieur le président il ya ce
mesdames messieurs les présidents
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs sans avoir été trop répétitive
je l'espère par rapport aux propos du
garde mais suffisamment précis pour
ensuite nourri un débat sous votre
autorité monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre
alors si vous permettez je vais poser
quelques questions plutôt
constitutionnel enfin les autres aussi
tout le monde va poser des questions
constitutionnelles ce soir et puis après
j'ai le le président arthuis et le
rapporteur général du budget philippe
marini qui sont co rapporteur pour la
commission des finances pour la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur alain vasselle rapporteur
général et rapporteur pour avis et la
présidente de la commission devra aussi
prendre la parole la présidente
et puis ensuite mes chers collègues vous
pourrez interroger les ministres alors
bien entendu dans un paddock demain ou
après demain sur freebox il y aura les
séances publiques enfin il y aura tout
un tas de raisons et d'occasion pour
nous exprimer
les prélats rappelé le ministre j'ai été
très frappé sur le e
je tiens à dire que l'article 2 bis et
l'article 9 bis ne figurait pas dans le
projet du gouvernement les articles 2
bis et 9 10 ce qui concerne le respect
du monopole ne figurait pas dans le
projet du gouvernement
et monsieur le ministre du budget j'ai
bien dit que le fait de ne pas respecter
la règle du mot de paul est un motif
d'inconstitutionnalité et et je pense
que à l'assemblée avec dans le débat etc
on est passé vite à problèmes
d'irrecevabilité ce qui est autre chose
et quand on m'a voc la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel
certes il ya la jurisprudence de
l'article 41 le non respect tu sais lire
sabilité mais en fait on met dans la
révision constitutionnelle que le fait
de ne pas respecter la règle d'or c'est
un motif d'inconstitutionnalité
donc à partir de ce
moment là qu'ils aient recevabilité ou
pas que se soit pas passé cet anti
constitutionnel et donc pourquoi aller
chercher des détours et des retours moi
je dis ou bien ou bien clairement c'est
inconstitutionnel si le conseil
constitutionnel est saisi ce que vous
dites d'ailleurs si le conseil
constitutionnel est saisi qui sera
obligé de dire c'est qu'on sait
contraires à la constitution
je me permets de faire cette observation
parce que je comprends bien j'ai lu les
débats à l'assemblée et cetera
l'irrecevabilité vous savez très bien
que l ai très peu mise en oeuvre
l'alarmisme mobilité de l'article 41 moi
je n'ai jamais vu au sénat avant
peut-être une fois l'assemblée parce
qu'en plus s'il ya des accords entre le
gouvernement et le président de
l'assemblée il faut aller au conseil
constitutionnel vous voyez que c'est
c'est quand même d'une simplicité
bon et puis mais par contre
inconstitutionnalité salle d'ailleurs
l'article 40 je rappelle aussi motif
d'inconstitutionnalité aussi et puis
tout un tas d'autres règles qui sont
contraires à la constitution
donc je je je me demande si on va pas
chercher si si on n'est pas un petit peu
contradictoire en ce qui concerne et
d'ailleurs ça ne cessé d ajouts qu'ont
apporté deuxième question mais ça c'est
la règle du monopole qui a sa cohérence
mais bien entendu on ne peut que
examiner avec attention les conséquences
sur le travail parlementaire parce que
l'examen d'une réforme
par exemple on en a eu et j'ai prévu et
parler de réformes récentes un réforme
des retraites logement environnement
recherche et cetera ne pourra plus
accompagné de discussion des moyens qui
renvoyait au projet de loi de finances
ou au projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
la discussion des projets de loi de
finances et des projets doivent
financement dont va concentrer un nombre
important disposition complétant les
réformes adoptées au cours de l'année
alors est ce qu'il n'ya pas quand il
s'agit d'une réforme importante le
l'occasion parfois de présenter une
ouate projet de loi de finances
rectificative
parce que autrement on va être un petit
peu je ne sais pas comment enfin je vois
pas comment on fait concrètement on voit
une réforme mais sans les moyens on dira
les moyens voulait alors ça arrive ça
arrive hein c'est pas mais si c'est
simple c'est facile mais quand c'est
vraiment une réforme d'importance je ne
sais pas comment on fait alors bien
entendu je me permets de vous dire que
cette question revêt un aspect plus
crucial pour le sénat car l'article 72
de la constitution impose que tout
transfert de compétences de l'état aux
collectivités territoriales
sa compagne de l'attribution de
ressources nécessaires
c'est la constitution avec la règle du
monopole
les dispositions financières et celles
organisant le transfert ne peuvent se
trouver dans le même texte
ce qui pose deux questions comment a dit
assurer la discussion de la réforme et
de son volet financier de façon
coordonnée
alors que la constitution donne au sénat
la priorité pour les textes relative aux
collectivités territoriales et à
l'assemblée nationale la priorité pour
les projets de loi de finances comment
le conseil constitutionnel pour at il
apprécié le respect de l'exigence de
compensation à l'occasion du contrôle
sur le texte opérant le transfert de
compétences bien entendu j'ai lu
récemment dans les débats à l'assemblée
qu'on n'était pas vrai des vrais
parlementaire qu'on était pas
représentants du peuple etc mais
néanmoins la constitution n'est pas dans
ce sens là il faudra que certains très
brillant relisent la constitution alors
autre question le monopole
s'appliqueraient indifféremment aux
mesures qui diminue les recettes les
dépenses fiscales uni et à celles qu'ils
accroissent on maintient le niveau
global dont qui il
on peut même pu gagner une paire de
recettes par une majoration d'imposition
mais alors quid des dispositions pour
conséquence une augmentation des
ressources publiques
c'est aussi dans les lois de finances je
suppose
alors je me suis ministre j'ai fait une
petite recherche parce que c'est
toujours intéressant
l'impact de la règle du monopole sur les
finances publiques
de 2000 à 2009 ces 68 milliards d'euros
de baisses d'impôt consenties en fait 57
milliards d'euros sont imputables à des
mesures prises dans les lois de finances
ou de financement de la sécurité sociale
et seuls 11 milliards sont pris dans les
lois ordinaires
il faut quand même le rappeler parce que
déjà c'est largement dans les lois de
finances que ces questions ont été
traitées sur le président arthuis ces 11
milliards de trop mais peut-être que les
57 milliards aussi alors et tout c'est
tout est relatif
non mais je parle comme jean arthuis
loyaux m'excuser vous savez je prend des
leçons tous les mains non que alors
ensuite une autre question le place des
lois de règlement par rapport à mesure
des écarts entre l'exécution des lois de
finances et les normes fixées par le wac
à des clips des finances publiques
c'est une question alors comment
concevez-vous le dispositif de
compensation des écarts temps pour les
lois de finances le pourrai loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
dernière question ou avant dernière
parce que l'on est j'en ai encore une
autre que
en ce qui concerne le projet de
stabilité la procédure retenue consiste
temps durera le parlement à voter sur un
texte sans avoir pu participer à son
élaboration est sûr que cela aboutisse à
son adoption
ce qui est sans précédent alors c'est
sans précédent
non mais on peut innover toujours est ce
qu il n qu'est-ce qui ne conviendrait
pas d'envisager sur les ministres ne
permettent au parlement d'adopter une
résolution sans mettre en cause la
responsabilité des gourmands sur le
modèle des résolutions darty 88,4
dernière question en ce qui concerne
nous renvoie beaucoup de choses à la loi
organique
moi je pense que les laits fait qu'on
puisse déroger 1 pour des raisons c'est
la loi fondamentale allemande est
extrêmement précis puisqu'il dit
circonstances exceptionnelles ne
dépendant pas du gouvernement ou
catastrophes naturelles il encadre
strictement et donc cccc s'il vous plaît
est-ce que d'une question ce qu on
renvoyait à une loi organique
moi je suis d'accord sur les modalités
c'est le rôle d'une loi organique
mais sur les principes de dérogations
éventuelles à la loi cadre
est ce que ça ne devrait pas figurer
dans la constitution ça reprend les
autres questions des présidents comme
moi et vous préférez comme où les
communes monsieur le président en appui
merci monsieur le président merci à vous
messieurs les ministres de venir nous
faire partager vos convictions sur la
nécessité de tendre vers l'équilibré de
nos finances publiques
car nous sommes tous attachés à la
souveraineté nationale
le président de la république et lui
même garant de l'indépendance nationale
et à n'en pas douter tout excès
d'endettement public peut remettre en
cause de façon sévère
cette indépendance nationale et le texte
qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui reprend
pour l'essentiel les conclusions du
groupe de travail qui a précisé michel
camdessus groupe au sein duquel philippe
marini et moi même
avons participé l'idée de faire des lois
de finances et des lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale le cadre exclusif
des dispositions nature fiscale et
sociale mettant en cause les finances
publiques nous paraît aller dans la
bonne direction et le principe d'une loi
cadre pluriannuel pour encadrer le
niveau des recettes et des dépenses afin
de tendre vers l'équilibré nous paraît
également une bonne orientation et le
texte tel qu'il nous vient de
l'assemblée nationale nous paraissait
pouvoir faire l'objet d'une approbation
mais je mesure à quel point la
contribution de la commission des lois
est essentiel pour parfaire pour
parfaire la rédaction du texte
si donc il devait y avoir une procédure
d'amendement
nous aurions sans doute quelques
quelques propositions qui viendrait en
complément des propositions de la
commission des lois
ce qui nous paraît très positif dans le
texte soumis au parlement et appeler un
portait réforme de la constitution c'est
que il nous apporte un ensemble de
règles de procédure et que nous avons
sans doute de ces procès du besoin de
ces procédures pour éviter
l'embardée des déficits publics alors
mon j'aurai une seule l'observation
affaires et philippe marini complétera
cette à propos de l'article 1er où l'on
dit est l'expression en soi et est
parlante et pédagogique
on fixera un plancher de recettes et un
plafond de dépenses et en disant cela en
parlant d'un minimum de recettes et d'un
maximum de dépenses on en vient à une
pure règle de solde effectifs ce qui
serait sans doute risqué au plan de la
du fonctionnement
donc ce que nous avions retenu dans la
commission camdessus
c'était non pas un un minimum de mesures
de recettes mais c'était un plancher de
mesures nouvelles de recettes et donc si
nous avions un amendement a proposé à
cet article 1er ce serait d'évoquer un
minimum de mesures nouvelles de recettes
je voudrais enfin interrogé le
gouvernement sur la loi organique et qui
ne prévoit pas d'encadrement des
hypothèses macroéconomiques
il pourrait y avoir là une difficulté
car si le gouvernement et si le
parlement retenait des hypothèses
macroéconomiques excessivement optimiste
volontariste il pourrait y avoir un
empêchement majeur à respecter la
trajectoire de soldes ceci n'est pas
prévue mais peut-être qu'on pourra
l'occasion du débat en séance publique
apporter quelques quelques éléments
substantiels pour que pour que personne
ne se méprenne et notamment le conseil
constitutionnel ayant dit cela je vais
laisser la parole ou important général
de la commission des finances
nous sommes co rapporteurs parce que
nous avons participé ensemble aux
travaux quand dessus monsieur le
président la commission des lois mais
messieurs les ministres
chers collègues tout d'abord je voudrais
réaffirmer l'opportunité et la nécessité
de cette révision constitutionnelle il
s'agit
pour notre pays de se doter de règles du
jeu au plus haut niveau de son ordre
juridique est en quelque sorte pour nous
protéger contre nous mêmes j'oserais
dire cela ou pour dire les choses
différemment pour que nos engagements de
convergence soit des engagements
véritablement porté par l'ensemble du
pays que cela reflète un effort partagé
quel que soit au demeurant les données
techniques des politiques en déduire
je pense que l'on aura observé que le
texte de la révision constitutionnelle
même s'il n'est pas parfait aux yeux de
notre excellente commission des lois
mais je ne sais pas s'il est des textes
qu'ils puissent se lui semblait parfait
dans le monde où nous vivons et mais ce
texte
cette révision constitutionnelle
n'aborde pas le fond des choses et
demeure texte de procédure et c'est
peut-être ce qui rend la mise au point
particulièrement délicate car le diable
est dans les détails et la procédure est
à faire naturellement complexe mais de
quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit de dire que les décisions qui
impacte le solde des finances publiques
doivent être prises dans des lois qui
sont précisément fait pour approuver ce
solde
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une loi de
finances rectificative
c'est une loi qui crée des charges des
ressources et surtout qui présente le
tableau d'ensemble c'est à dire la
rectification du budget initial en
tenant compte des éléments que l'on
ajoute on retranche c'est à la vérité la
seule vertu d'une loi rectificative
c'est de conduire à voter une nouvelle
fois le tableau d' équilibre général et
parmi les quelques petites mesures à 11
milliards d'euros je n'ai pas vérifié le
total qui ont été opportunément évoqué
tout à l'heure par le président jean
jacques hyest
il ya par exemple la fixation du taux de
tva dans la restauration mais je ne je
n'exprimerais pas de deux jugements de
valeur bon je crois que la commission
des finances a suffisamment dit et écrit
sur ce sujet mais simplement sans doute
était-il regrettable et quel que soit
notre opinion sur le fond mes chers
collègues nous pouvons y réfléchir de ne
n'avoir pas voté cette mesure avec le
tableau d' équilibre général n'est ce
pas ensuite et il est indiqué que les
lois de finances et lois de financement
leur soeur jumelle doivent être en
quelque sorte
encadrée par des textes pluriannuel lois
cadres de programmation des finances
publiques doivent être conformes et qui
dit conformes dit qu'un arbitre doit
dire ou ne pas dire la conformité
qui est cet arbitre comment le cesit on
sait le conseil constitutionnel et ce
sont en effet les dispositions votées à
l'assemblée nationale et qui met le
conseil constitutionnel en capacité
d'arbitré voilà sur le fond pour la
commission des finances comme l'a dit le
président arthuis c'est bien l'essentiel
est de ce point de vue les équilibres
auxquels nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale sont parvenus nous semble être
un bon équilibre et c'est pourquoi en ce
qui nous concerne il ne nous semble pas
absolument indispensable d'amender ce
texte
maintenant que ce texte ne soit pas
parfait dans le monde imparfait où nous
vivons c'est tout à fait certain qu'il
soit possible de l'améliorer
c'est tout à fait certain et si cet
effort d'amélioration est entamée
naturellement nous nous efforcerons de
notre côté d'apporter notre pierre pour
que ces améliorations soient les les les
plus satisfaisants aussi donc sans
entrer vraiment dans le dans le détail
des choses je dirais que qu'une démarche
d'amélioration nous conduirait à
préciser certaines questions de délais
d'examen et qu'une telle démarche nous
conduirait à aa a précisé certains
aspects du contrôle de conformité aux
lois cadres et s
l'ensemble loi de finances ou loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
doit faire l'objet d'une saisine
automatique et s'agit-il seulement des
loi initial qu'elle soit de finances ou
de financement de la sécurité sociale
et que se passe-t-il en cas de non
conformité
quelles sont les sanctions et en cas de
non-conformité considérer ton qu'il y a
par là même de ce fait même
inconstitutionnalité et et et bien sûr
tous ces aspects et doivent être
précisées ils peuvent l'être à mon sens
par les travaux préparatoires comme il
pourrait l'être si l'on voulait
absolument tout gravé dans le marbre par
le texte lui même
enfin il me semble que l'on pourrait
aussi apporter des précisions sur les
conditions de vote des projets de
programmes de stabilité et je je je
terminerai en évoquant la notion de
règles de gestion des finances publiques
et qui
doit recouvrir les principes
structurants les principes permanent et
ce qui nécessite sans doute une
définition du contenu de cette catégorie
voilà monsieur le président quelques et
quelques quelques réactions encore une
fois permettez moi de le redire
le texte voté à l'assemblée nationale me
paraît être un bon texte est un bon
compromis entre les approches de nos des
différentes commissions de l'assemblée
nationale
je crois que nous pouvons saluer le
travail de qualité qui a été fait par
nos collègues députés
incontestablement surtout quand on lit
que le conseil constitutionnel examine
la conformité à la constitution des
dispositions qui méconnaissent le
domaine réservé à la loi et aux
règlements
c'est vrai que c'est une formule qui
peut rester dans une constitution mais
franchement
peut-être que la commission des lois est
perfectionniste mais il s'agit quand
même de la constitution
ok les c'est ce qui a été écrit
franchement monsieur le rapporteur gêne
le rapporteur général de la commission
des affaires sociales est monsieur le
président merci messieurs les ministres
messieurs les présidents du cher
collègue vous permettrez de trois
remarques avant de de m'interroger sur
deux points qui résultent de l'examen
auquel nous avons précédé de ce texte et
pour lequel nous sommes saisis au niveau
de la commission des affaires sociales
pour habib fera une première marque en
direction du gouvernement pour émettre
un regret c'est que au moment où le
groupe de travail ou la commission le
groupe conçu campus est mise en place
c'est que la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat autres travers son
président et son rapporteur n'ait pas
été associé à ces travaux je crois qu'on
peut pas considérer quesnoy de
financement qui est la variable qui
pourrait être considéré comme la
variable d'ajustement de la loi de
finances ne le pense que c'est ni dans
l'esprit du gouvernement dit dans
l'esprit des deux commissions des
présidents et des rapporteurs
donc j'ai jamais ce regret qui ne
changera rien au stade où nous en sommes
mais je pense que si nous l'avions fait
ensemble s'arrêter cette réflexion
préféré sur les sur l'état des lieux où
le diagnostic nous le partageons
totalement sur la situation donc des
finances publiques
du point de vue des finances de la
sécurité sociale je fais remarquer au
passage que si la situation financière
de la sécurité sociale s'est trouvée
dégradé comme cette des finances c'est
bien le résultat
les conséquences de la crise financière
qui nous vient des états unis qui a fait
doubler le déficit est passé de 10 à
familiale ceci étant nous n'avons sommes
pas rester sans agir le gouvernement en
plein accord avec la commission des
affaires sociales celles des finances
puisque des mesures fortes ont été
prises il ya eu la première reprise de
dette par la cades s et puis la seconde
mesure c'était la réforme des retraites
est justement la réforme des retraites
est un élément qui doit nous éclairer
sur les mesures que nous devons prendre
dans le cadre de cette réforme
constitutionnelle j'y reviendrai dans un
instant sur les objectifs donc nous
partageons totalement et sur les
principes tels qu'ils ont été énoncés
par monsieur le garde des sceaux il n'ya
pas mais donc d'opposition d'autre part
parce que c'est plutôt sur les modalités
que nous divergeons et sur lesquelles il
y aurait à mon sens quelques
améliorations à apporter
alors bien entendu sur les modalités je
vais entendre par avance des propos qui
pond qui vont être tenues c'est de dire
sur les modalités on arrivera toujours à
s'entendre
mais s'agissant d'une réforme
constitutionnelle et que réformes dans
lequel on veut graver dans le marbre un
certain nombre de principes forts il
faut que ces principes soient
accompagnés donc de modalités à la fois
à travers la mise en oeuvre et le
contrôle donc d'aider des déficits et
des soldes par la commission des
finances et la commission des affaires
sociales
ça m'amène à venir à mes deux
interrogations la première ce concerne
la procédure d'adoption des lois cadres
dès lors qu elles définiront une
trajectoire qui s'imposera aux lois de
finances et aux lois de financement
il me semble qui serait utile de prévoir
des règles différentes de celles qui
sont aujourd'hui appliqués par des
doigts programmation des finances
publiques
aujourd'hui ces projets de loi sont
renvoyés pour examen au fond à la
commission des finances et la commission
des affaires sociales n'est saisie que
pour avis si nous ne prévoyons rien il
en ira de même pour les projets de lois
cadres d'équilibré des finances
publiques philippe marini a dit à
l'instant même que ce sont deux lois
jumelles mais j'en ai entretenu
plusieurs fois à temps avec lui qu'avec
le président de la commission des
finances pour considérer que nous devons
travailler de concert et de père sur ses
doigts de financer ses doigts de
financement et dans l'esprit ni de
l'inde et l'autre qui l'y a pour
objectif de faire dominer une loi sur
une autre c'est au contraire c'est
suivent essayer de défendre l'intérêt
général et de veiller à ce que
l'équilibré des comptes soit au rendez
vous et nous sommes animés de la même
volonté
donc je souhaite que sur ce point il
puisse y avoir une amélioration qui
pourrait s'imaginer s'agissant donc
d'une loi qui ne sera revue que tous les
trois cas
proulx cinq ans on pourrait imaginer la
création d'une commission spéciale
composée des membres de la commission
chargée d'examiner les lois de finances
et la commission chargée d'examiner les
lois de financement
une telle commission spéciale
permettrait de faire travailler vraiment
ensemble les parlementaires spécialistes
du budget détail ceux du budget de la
sécurité sociale
meba seconde question vise le monopole
sur le monopole des lois financières
pour les impositions de toute nature et
les recettes de la sécurité sociale
c'est là où j'en viens à la référence à
la réforme des retraites la dispersion
des mesures fiscales et des dispositions
relatives aux recettes de l'insulté
social dans une multitude de textes est
une difficulté dans la commission des
affaires sociales est consciente depuis
longtemps toutefois nous sommes inquiets
des conséquences du monopole des lois
financières tel qu'il est pour l'instant
prévue dans le projet de loi ne
risque-t-on pas de rendre le travail
parlementaire beaucoup plus difficile
en scindant toutes les réformes comme
cela a été fait pour la réforme des
retraites peut-on d'ores et déjà peut-on
sérieusement adopté un projet de loi sur
un sujet donné et renvoyé à la loi de
finances à la loi de financement
l'analyse de ces conséquences
financières c'est ce qui se fait passer
lorsque nous avons examiné la réforme
des retraites
toutes les réformes importantes risque à
l'avenir d'être découpée en morceaux et
nous aurons le plus grand mal à les
appréhender dans leur globalité je
l'aidais donc c'est babel moment nous
avons examiné la réforme des retraites
puisque les mesures essentielles étaient
des mesures financières elles n'ont pas
été traités au mans nous avons examiné
la réforme est renvoyé à la loi de
finances à la loi de financement
d'autres solutions sont elles
envisageables en 2008 de traces
je rappelle que notre assemblée a adopté
une proposition de loi organique qui
subordonnait l'entrée en vigueur de
toute exonération cotisations sociales à
une approbation par la loi de
financement
même si la mesure avait été prise dans
un autre texte
est-ce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une voix
qui aurait lieu d'explorer il me semble
que le minimum serait de prévoir que
lorsqu'une réforme comporte des
implications financières elle doit être
accompagnée d'un projet de loi de
finances ou de loi de financement
rectificatif à débattre en même temps
que le têt posant les principes de la
réforme
d'ailleurs je note au passage que le
gouvernement n'hésite pas pour la
première fois
à envisager une loi rectificative
à la suite de mesures qui vont être
qu'ils vont être pris notamment avec
cette fameuse prime de 1000 euros et où
on aura une loi rectificative à examiner
donc a fortiori je pense que lorsqu'on
aura examiné des réformes de l'ampleur
d'une réforme des retraites
il me semble qu'une mesure du type de
celle que nous proposons m'apparaîtrait
tout à fait pertinente
enfin je terminerais pour faire allusion
à la procédure de recevabilité qui a été
votée à l'assemblée
nous nous interrogeons sur sa cohérence
dès lors que les de solvabilité serait
soulevée de manière facultative par le
gouvernement mais que le conseil
constitutionnel serait pour sa part tenu
de censuré les dispositions qui ne
respecteraient pas le monopole de loi
financière
ceci nous a interpellés voilà monsieur
le président merci monsieur le
rapporteur général madame la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres messieurs les présidents
chers collègues je serais bref parce qu
alain vasselle a été particulièrement
explicite sur les préoccupations de
notre commission et mais je voudrais
quand même insisté sur le fait que ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle s'il est
un outil de maîtrise de nos finances
publiques tout à fait intéressant ne
devrait pas constituer un nouvel
instrument de parlementarisme
rationnalisé je m'explique en mettant
bout à bout l'article 40 de la
constitution l'interdiction des
cavaliers budgétaires et des cavaliers
sociaux et en ajoutant le monopole des
lois financières en matière de recettes
de l'état et de la sécurité sociale tel
qu'il est prévu
nous risquons de rendre impossible toute
discussion cohérente et argumentée de
réformes qui nous sont proposés
d'autres solutions ne mérite t elle pas
d'être examinées qu'il s'agisse des lois
de prélèvements obligatoires proposée
par gilles carez ou de la validation des
mesures prises en cours d'année par les
lois financières telle que l'avait
proposé nicolas à bout et alain vasselle
en 2008 il me semble très important de
faire en sorte que la volonté de
maîtrise de nos finances publiques ne
conduisent pas à brider un peu plus le
parlement
la question de la procédure d'adoption
des lois cadres d'équilibré des finances
publiques est essentiel pour la
commission des affaires sociales la
fixation de normes pluriannuel
s'imposant à la loi de finances comme à
la loi de financement ne peut se faire
que dans le cadre d'un travail commun
entre les commissions compétentes pour
examiner ces deux lois
je soutiens donc l'idée de prévoir la
constitution d'une commission spéciale
pour l'examen de ce projet de loi je
m'interroge par ailleurs sur la
procédure car tenu l'assemblée nationale
pour l'examen des projets de programmes
de stabilité
l amp en effet prévu le renvoi du projet
de programme je cite pour avis à l'une
des commissions permanentes
cela signifie thivet ce serait singulier
que les autres commissions ne pourront
pas donner d'avis si al'inverse les
autres commissions peuvent donner un
avis à quoi sert cette mention je vous
remercie d explication que vous pourrez
nous apporter merci
le midi bouclé bien merci aussi
président nous allons faire ça en deux
temps garde répondre à tous les autres
sujets je vais essayer d'aller à
l'essentiel sur les différents points
qui ont été soulevés qui sont évidemment
des points fondamentaux comment monsieur
le président y est vous avez évoqué à la
fois l'application de l'article 40 et
d'autre part l'application ou la faible
application de l'article 41 sur la
recevabilité par le président
l'assemblée ou par le gouvernement qui a
toujours la faculté de saisir sur le
caractère recevable ou pas de nature
notamment réglementaires moi j'ai le
souvenir notamment du débat sur les
retraites mais version raffarin pas là
la récente réforme qu'il y a eu de la
part du président debré à l'époque
président de l'assemblée nationale une
saisine sur plusieurs milliers puisqu'il
ya une espèce de deux phénomènes de
gremlins ces amendements s'était
reproduit avec juste des petites gouttes
d'eau et comme c'était les mêmes on
était monté à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers il y avait eu une forme presque
d'instinct de survie dans la qualité du
débat parlementaire où le président
s'est appuyé sur le quart en terre donc
l'histoire récente a montré que ça
pouvait être utile ça a été efficace et
d'ailleurs il faut dire ça va dissuader
un peu une partie de la flibusterie de
l'époque de poursuivre son avantage et
de poursuivre non pas sur trois semaines
de débats mais sur trois mois ou sur
quatre mois donc ça avait stoppé net ce
41 existe il faut bien voir que l'
équilibre général obtenu autour du 41
est le fruit d'une très longue
discussion entre la commission des
finances à l'assemblée le rapporteur
général du budget et votre mot log
monsieur le président à la commission
des lois
c'est un élément de réponse à madame
diniz sur la problématique de la loi de
prélèvements obligatoires
disons les choses comme elles sont la
loi prélèvements obligatoires conférait
sous l'impulsion du rapporteur général
un tel pouvoir dans l'organisation du
travail parlementaire que la réaction
n'a pas été réservé de la part du
gouvernement mais elle a été presque
bloquante de la part des autres
commissions et des autres présidents de
commissions ce qui peut se comprendre
quand on a une culture par le vol
parlementaire et ainsi nous avons oublié
la problématique la ouate prélèvements
obligatoires et nous sommes allés sur
une déclinaison élargie de l'article
31 passes ont comme vous l'avez dit de
l'irrecevabilité à
l'inconstitutionnalité notamment dans le
cadre du monopole des lois de finances
et de financement de la sécurité sociale
donc pour répondre à ce premier point
monsieur y est ça existe et il est l art
jc de notre point de vue un bon
équilibre parce qu'il atteint l'objectif
que nous souhaitons parce que je le
rappelle nous sommes dans un contexte de
crise budgétaire de disette budgétaire
d'exigence des objectifs intangibles de
réduction des déficits publics nous
avons des rendez vous ces rendez-vous
nous emmène au moins jusqu'en 2014
puisque je rappelle que la france a fixé
à 2% niveau déficit en 2014 que
l'allemagne s'est dotée d'une règle d'or
qui suffit de regarder autour de la
france qui se passe actuellement je
parle même pas de la grèce je parle même
pas de l'espagne je pense aux mesures
mot talent je pense à l'irlande
je pense à ce que les agences de
notation sont en train d'organiser en
termes de regards des investisseurs sur
la belgique sur les états unis ou sur
l'italie il me semble que la
démonstration est faite que nous avons
besoin de nous doter de façon méthodique
d'outils qui trouve le juste équilibre
entre le respect d'initiative
parlementaire et en même temps
l'objectif affirmé par la france
d'atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire
l'article 41 est un bon équilibre nous
sommes satisfaits et nous sommes
félicités la qualité du débat sur la
partie initiative parlementaire mme là
je vais aller à l'essentiel vous avec l
article 72 2 de la constitution
notamment pour tout ce qui concerne le
transfert de compétences en réalité
c'est déjà le cas car toutes les mesures
qui portent sur les collectivités
territoriales sont déjà examiné dans les
lois de finances par loi de financement
de sécurité sociale mais les lois de
finances et il n'y a pas de difficulté
dans la maîtrise de l'ordre du jour de
rendre compatibles 72,2 et de rendre
compatible également l'application du 41
modifié puisque si nous serons dans la
logique du monopole des lois de finances
et des dispositifs fiscale mais avec un
rang prioritaire pour la haute assemblée
puisque ça concerne les compétences
territoriales et l'autonomie
territoriale donc ne sont que comme
c'est déjà le cas je ne vois pas ce que
cette révision constitutionnelle
pourrait entraîner comme modifications
négatives pour les sénats et sa
représentativité des collectivités
locales le troisième point que vous
abordez sur le plancher de recettes et
le plafond de dépenses vous avez raison
de dire et je soutiens pleinement votre
position que une très large partie de
l'initiative des mesures dérogatoires en
matière fiscale ou sociale et
d'initiative gouvernementale
c'est pour ça que dans nos propos
liminaire le garde des sceaux et moi
même nous avons insisté sur le fait que
les mesures qui sont des mesures plus
restrictives
puisqu'il s'agit d'atteindre l'équilibré
budgétaire que nous n'y sommes pas
parvenus que nous avons besoin d'être au
rendez vous de ce que nous avons pris
comme engagements vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires
et donc c'est un effort collectif
parlement et gouvernement mais que
l'essentiel des mesures concernant
l'application du monopole du monopole
s'applique ont d'abord et avant tout au
gouvernement c'est d'abord le
gouvernement qui va se mettre en
situation évidemment de respecter la
constitution
le parlement est impacté de façon
marginale et je voudrais dire puisque
vous avez abordé ce point c'est que si
c'est vous ou si c'est le président
arthuis qui est le quatrième point votre
intervention
cette problématique je le disais aussi
dans mon introduction on a désormais
tous les ans un collectif budgétaire
il rapporte en général a évoqué il
s'agit de stabiliser à mi parcours
l'équilibré général du budget en
fonction de l'évolution au cours des six
premiers mois
donc nous sommes là aussi dans des
rendez vous qui me semble pas être un
horizon du forestier insupportable pour
le parlementaire qui auraient envie de
s'investir je ne sais pas sur la
politique du logement où ça a été évoqué
sur la restauration et voir de quelle
manière on peut imaginer tv au
dérogatoire ça a été fait mais admettons
ce cas de figure n'aurait pas existé
et bien il y aurait eu tout à fait la
faculté de dire pour les industries de
main d'oeuvre
nous avons besoin d'une politique on
affirme dans les discours une politique
dans un texte et de se donner
rendez-vous deux ou trois mois plus tard
au mois de juin pour voir quelles sont
les modalités
dérogatoire imposé dans les lois finance
donc je crois que nous avons quand même
deux rendez vous désormais régulier et
le collectif social je le rappelle
encore montre que nous pouvons aussi
avoir des rendez vous sur la partie
financement de la sécurité sociale sur
les lois de règlement j'y suis allé sur
le programme de stabilité je pense
vraiment que là c'est une avancée
française qui est importante alors vous
dites mais ce qu'on pourrait pas
constitutionnaliser l'idée de résolution
dans la mesure où la résolution trouve
quand même déjà son point d'appui dans
les articles constitutionnels
je crois que ce serait au fond pas
forcément cohérent avec justement le
fait de laisser l'initiative
parlementaire se dérouler nous sommes
entendus ensemble sur le fait que la
résolution ni siat yves parlementaire
était la meilleure problématique pour
accompagner à travers un vote
les propositions du gouvernement après
andy mais il faut avec le parlement
soient associés aux propositions
peut-être mais nous sommes encore sous
la vème république si je puis me
permettre
et l'exécutif a une responsabilité
justement dans le l'exécution et dans la
présentation c'est déjà une avancée
considérable que d'avoir effectué au
mois de juillet dernier la présentation
du programme de stabilité certes avec un
peu de décalage de deux mois et un vote
assemblée sénat
est ce que nous avons vécu au mois
d'avril était une avancée elle
spectaculaire parce que me semblait
vraiment inscrire durablement dans le
calendrier est dans nos méthodes de
travail en commun la capacité pour le
gouvernement ne vous dira voilà où nous
en sommes voilà ce que nous allons dire
voilà quels sont nos engagements vous
parlement qu'en pensez vous donc un rôle
à la fois d'initiative et de contrôle et
ça prend la forme
si la résolution est adoptée d'un
accompagnement majoritaire et donc ça
donne aussi beaucoup de poids au
gouvernement sur les lois et ses
derniers points que vous avez abordé
monsieur le président y est la loi
organique et le fait de mettre les
circonstances exceptionnelles je crois
qu'il vaut mieux les mettre en effet
dans la loi organique elle est placée
avec un parallélisme des formes avec
l'allemagne moi qui me gêne en aucune
façon les circonstances exceptionnelles
c'est la grande crise mondiale qu'on a
vécu
c'est par exemple fukushima ça pourrait
être d'autre élément ça peut être la
sécheresse ça peut être la sécheresse en
cours que là on a déjà des dispositifs
j'espère que ça nous aura entraînera pas
sur des situations qui nous amènerait à
déroger à cette évolution
mais nous pouvons parfaitement les
placer dans la loi organique et là
évidemment le terrain et ready pour en
parler voilà je me suis forcée d'aller à
l'essentiel sur vos interventions que
sur le président yes nous en avons parlé
vous connaissiez les positions du
gouvernement monsieur le président à
tuer d'abord je voudrais vous remercier
ainsi que rapporteur général d'avoir
participé très utilement aux travaux du
comité camdessus
vous avez un rôle majeur dans la
définition de ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui
alors monsieur le président la
commission des finances ont parlé d'un
minimum de nouvelles recettes
supplémentaires bon on a trouvé un point
d'équilibré avec l'assemblée il me
semble qu'à ce stade ça ne rajouterai
pas grand chose à la faire ni à la
puissance de cette révision
constitutionnelle je crois que les lois
de finances année après année
permettront de lister les mesures de
recettes nouvelles
si nous avions des dégradations mais
nous ne pouvons pas avoir de dégradation
puisque nous sommes vraiment rentrer
dans une logique vertueuse de réduction
de déficits donc je pense que cette
menace elle est éloignée pour un certain
temps ensuite inscrire les hypothèses
macroéconomiques dans la loi
fondamentale savoir ça c'est une autre
paire de manches si je puis me permettre
parce qu'il faudrait s'entendre déjà sur
la méthode sur les objectifs sur les
éléments du consensus
sur quelle base est ce que c'est un
consensus national est ce que c'est un
consensus européen
est-ce qu'on s'appuie sur les
statistiques d'eurostat tu es ce que
c'est uniquement les statistiques de
l'insee
vous savez clean s'échangent également
sa base d' analyse tous les quatre ou
cinq ans on l'a vu encore récemment
donc il me semble qu'il ya trop de parts
à la subjectivité pour prendre le risque
d'inscrire dans la constitution même des
repères pour autant il me semble que la
loi organique pourrait peut-être dans
nos débats définir ce qui pourrait être
le minimum de points de repère
acceptable pour définir un consensus et
qu'on est peut-être moins deux variables
de débats lorsque nous présentons les
lois de finances
je voudrais en tout cas vous remercier
pour le regard que vous avez porté jugez
par vous même très positif sur ce texte
et sur l' équilibre retrouvé je remercie
évidemment très chaleureusement le
rapporteur général
chacun sait aussi son implication et je
partage pourquoi le taire pleinement son
avis sur l'objectif qui ne me semble pas
inatteignable d'avoir un vote conforme
ce qui donnerait une très forte
puissance sans altérer en aucune façon
la qualité de recommandations de la
commission des lois une très forte
puissance à l'initiative d'aboutir à un
texte qui modifie notre constitution et
qui fixe une règle d'or monsieur
vasselle j'ai bien entendu tout ce que
vous m'avez dit je n'oublie rien au
débat sur la cades est ce je n'oublie
pas non plus l'expérimentation récente
du débat qu'on aille vous l'avez vous
même site et sur la loi sur les
retraites où nous avons eu des
perspectives avec des objectifs et nous
avons eu des modalités dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
assurer le financement de cette réforme
des retraites donc nous avons déjà eu
l'expérience de ce double schéma d'une
loi a vocation large et deux mesures
à l'intérieur de cette loi qui ont été
décalés dans l'examen pour être examiné
dans le cadre du financement de la
sécurité sociale je pense de ce point de
vue c'est un bon résultat j'ai bien
entendu votre regret de ne pas avoir
participé au comité et quand dessus
direct derrière nous et qui font tirer
la leçon et l'enseignement il est
évidemment incontestable compte tenu du
poids du financement de la sécurité
sociale que la commission ne vous êtes
le rapporteur soient pleinement
associées à tous ces travaux ce qui
m'amène évidemment répondre on dernier à
madame la présidente dit mise sur le
parent parlementarisme rationnalisé mois
pour avoir 20 ans d'expérience
parlementaire je trouve que les deux
révisions constitutionnelles celle de
2008 et celles ci sont très
complémentaires
et j'ajoute que c'est une conscience
collective d'un temps qui doit être
derrière nous cette exigence du retour à
l'équilibré de nos finances publiques
aussi bien évidemment financement des
des politiques publiques pour lancions
de l'action de quotidiens que pour le
financement de notre protection sociale
qui représente quand même une fois et
demie le budget de l'état
font désormais partie où que l'on se
trouve sur les bancs de l'assemblée des
priorités politiques de toute action
gouvernementale de toute action
majoritaire et je dirais même de tout
engagement sincère dans le cadre de
l'intérêt général de l'apport des
oppositions quelle qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient d'aujourd'hui où qu'elles soient
d'après après après demain je fixe à un
terme le plus lointain possible pour
évidemment nous encourage à poursuivre
notre action mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que je crois vraiment que c'est
pas une affaire gouvernement majorité et
opposition je crois vraiment que c'est
pas une affaire de droite ou de gauche
je crois profondément que c'est une
affaire de responsabilité collective
tous les gouvernements aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient dirigés par la gauche ou
par la droite sont dans l'obligation de
se placer dans cette situation monsieur
zapatero que je sache est un premier
ministre qui ne partagent pas les
options politiques du gouvernement
auquel nous appartenons et pourtant il
s'est mis dans la situation d'offrir dès
réponses budgétaires de réduction de
traitement de retraite de fonctionnaires
les résultats sont peut-être cela mais
il faut imaginer la situation si ces
mesures n'avaient pas été prises je
crois que voilà il faut quand même ne
pas oublier l'addition des différentes
répliques que nous avons vécu en europe
il faut quand même regarder ce qui se
passe sur la situation de notre monnaie
commune
aujourd'hui il faut mesurer que l'europe
a mis en place un fonds européen de
stabilité financière à court terme et un
mécanisme européen de stabilité
financière à long terme donc la
solidarité la défense de notre monnaie
la préservation de notre modèle social
justifie pleinement la défense de ce
projet
merci monsieur le ministre contrairement
à ce que certains pourraient penser le
droit pour senna d'améliorer un test
déjà parfait de l'assemblée n'est quand
même pas quelque chose qui me paraît
même si on est d'accord avec toute la
finalité de la réforme constitutionnelle
et je tiens à dire que je suis favorable
mais quand même parce qu'autrement peut
on peut arrêter tout de suite à pour
ceux qui titube encore quelques
questions à se poser sur cette révision
et qui ne sont pas convaincus qu'il faut
voter conforme et bien nous pouvons
peut-être interrogé monsieur garder sort
merci encore monsieur le ministre du
budget de sa présence madame briques
à ce stade je ferai des observations
rapide pour ne pas laisser la majorité
en tête à tête avec elle même vous avez
parlé des procédures monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget et monsieur
le président moi j'utiliserai plus tôt
une métaphore on ce texte ce sont des
poupées russes finalement qui c'est une
loi qui a une ambition constitutionnel
qui renvoie une loi organique et qui
renvoient elles mêmes à une loi-cadre
donc dans les modalités et le calendrier
ne sont pas définies donc je ma première
interrogation c'est quelle est la portée
effective de cet exercice je le concède
de procédures l'opérationnalité du texte
surtout nous sommes en 2011 ça n'échappe
à personne
la deuxième observation ministre du
budget partie bon il a invoqué il a
invoqué la crise mais tout le monde sait
que elle n'explique pas tout dans la
dérive des déficits et l'emballement de
la dette
on y fera référence dans le débat
général
et quand on regarde le passé
les dix dernières années vous l'avez
fait monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
mais si il fallait se garder d' aggraver
les déficits
je pense qu'il aurait fallu y penser dès
2007 cycle était quand même plus
convenable parce que la machine était
déjà emballée depuis 2002 la non
préservation des recettes
on y non non je ne dis pas ça je ne dis
pas ça je ne dis pas ça au menu
c'est ma deuxième tour je me rendre aux
fins que c'est ma deuxième interrogation
que ne l'avez vous pas c'est dès 2007
vous avez pris le chemin contraire alors
s'agissant de se garder de de nous mêmes
quelle que soit la majorité qui sera
issu de des urnes en 2012 puisque et
après bien sûr ban
donc oui pour les siècles à venir mais
bon comme disait keynes à long terme
nous serons tous morts mais c'est la
dernière observation que je que je veux
faire quand on regarde l'évolution
récente nous avons une preuve un
programme de stabilité
nous avons un engagement européen de
revenir dans les clous d'un pacte de
stabilité
et bien quand on fait le compte
la contrainte est déjà très lourdes à
l'intérieur de ce cadre
puisque ça a fait dire à monsieur
trichet président de la banque centrale
européenne qu'on était dans une quasi
fédération budgétaire et le semestre
européen qui a des avantages qu'ils
donnent aux parlements nationaux une
sanction
au départ quand on envoie chaque année
la programmation est une sanction au
retour
de l'examen par la commission eh bien je
pense que ce cadre là c'est ça veut dire
que vous doutez de vous même si en plus
vous voulez faire une nouvelle procédure
j'ai 10 ans portée effective
vous doutez de vous-même pour l'avenir
parce que si on ajoute ce pacte ce
programme le semestre qui donne une
petite voix au peuple au travers des
parlements nationaux une toute petite
voix je pense que le conti y est je peux
peut-être que vous penser la même chose
que moi monsieur le ministre vous
acquiescez
on est bien à monsieur le président
fourcade
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
si je suis pleinement d'accord sur
l'objectif qui consiste à inscrire dans
la constitution la notion d' équilibre
des finances publiques compte tenu de ce
qui se passe depuis 1974 où je fus le
dernier a présenté un budget en
équilibre
ouais mais qui sait déséquilibrant 75
compte tenu du déficit pétroliers je
suis inquiet sur deux ou trois
formulation du texte première
formulation autant il est clair va le
début du texte qu'il s'agit de mettre en
oeuvre des lois cadres d'équilibré des
finances publiques couvrant à la fois la
totalité du secteur public et la
totalité de la sécurité sociale le fait
de dire à la suite en vue d'assurer
l'équilibré des comptes des
administrations publiques
il me semble qu'au point de vue
juridique pure et au point de vue
international
ceci ne couvrant pas le financement des
intérêts de la dette publique ni de
celle de l'état ni de celle de la
sécurité sociale
par conséquent je pense que la baule
rédaction financière faite par un
praticien consisterait à écrire en vue
d'assurer les en vue d'assurer
les lois cadres d'équilibré des finances
publiques déterminé cetera en vue d'un
sirh en vue d'assurer leur équilibre
parce que le fait de passer de la notion
de finance publique à la notion d'
équilibre des comptes des
administrations publiques
me paraît réservé un trou qui est celui
des intérêts de la dette
ceci me paraît important car les
intérêts de la dette vont représenter
dans les années qui viennent
compte tenu du stock que nous avons même
si nous stabilisons un chiffre important
qui va dépasser 55 milliards dès cette
année 60 l'année prochaine par
conséquent il ya la maladie un problème
qui me sur lequel il faut réagir
deuxième observation dans le même
article on part de la compensation des
écarts constatés et on renvoie ça à une
loi organique
or tout est là tout le problème c'est la
compensation des écarts et par
conséquent j'aurais aimé quelques
explications sur les mécanismes de
compensation des écarts car cette hausse
s'agit-il lorsqu'il y aura un écart
résultant d'une crise internationale
grave je pense que dans le blog a dit
qu'on mettra mécanisme de clause avec
bien sûr mais dans une mécanisme
ordinaire de gestion si un écart est ce
que c'était car sera compensée dès
l'année même ce qui veut dire qu'il
faudra prévoir des ressources dans le
cadre d'année
sera-t-il compenser l'année suivant
cette notion de compensation des écarts
dans des conditions qui seront prévues
par le organique ne sont pas claires
enfin troisième et dernier point je
m'arrêterai là sur l'article 41 alors
l'article 41 qui prévoit que lorsqu'une
proposition en amendement n'est pas du
domaine de la loi ou est contraire aux
délégations et là je l'assemblée a
ajouté le 20e mineur article 34 le 14e
le quatrième aline l'attirent 72 et
cetera et cetera
en cas de désaccord entre le
gouvernement le président de l'assemblée
intéressés le conseil constitutionnel
statue dans un délai de huit jours
ça veut dire que le but
g et la loi de financement de sécurité
sociale en cas de désaccord ne se rend
jamais voté le 31 décembre
alors je voulais quand même je voulais
quand même bien expliquer cette affaire
faut en avoir conscience
ça veut dire que nous poursuivrons
compte tenu des délais donnés au conseil
constitutionnel pour statuer sur un
amendement
souvenez vous un amendement ou sur une
proposition
ça veut dire que nous entrerons dans un
mécanisme dans lequel les budgets et les
lois de financements sont votés courant
du mois de janvier de l'année suivante
il faudra recourir la merveilleuse
technique du douzième provisoire
remarquer le gouvernement belge vit
aujourd'hui
depuis un an avec les douzièmes
provisoires et il ne s'en porte pas mal
mais je trouve que tout même c'est
dangereux dont il me semble monsieur le
ministre monsieur le garde des sceaux
que ou bien il faut une explication
précise sur ces problèmes concrets
ou bien il faut une modification de
texte mais je ne peux pas apporter ma
caution m'a garanti un texte qui recèle
de tels imperfections
alors on continue sur le dernier point
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président fourcade
en fait c'est pour tout amendement qui
ne respecteraient pas la norme
donc c'est pas dans la loi de finances
par définition puisque dans la loi de
finances on peut faire des amendements
donc c'est pour les autres toi qui ne
respecteraient pas donc c'est paf c'est
pas au moment de la loi de finances est
pas pour le vote de la loi de finances
ça serait pour une ode autre loi il y a
aussi le mot propositions oui avant les
propositions sur des propositions
peuvent être faites au moment de
l'examen de la loi de finances ouaip ils
essayent tout et pour tout les
propositions de l'eau à la bouche
par contre je ne sais pas sûr c'est
tellement rendu compte ce qui allait se
passer bon enfin tant mieux un bravo qui
quarante corps va appliquer alors on
continue si vous le voulez bien
il ya monsieur colin oui monsieur le
ministre garde des sceaux bis sous la
le projet qui nous rassemblent
aujourd'hui est pavé de bonnes
intentions comme l'enfer d'ailleurs du
même dans cette démarche si j'ai bien
compris la dépossession imposé à
l'ordinaire de la matière fiscale et
contraire me semble-t-il à notre
tradition juridique et politique du
premier pôle les lois des finances somme
d'initiatives gouvernementales
chacun de ces les parlementaires devront
donc j'imagine attendre une telle
initiative du gouvernement ce qui nous
paraît pour créer ou aménager
l'imposition c'est politiquement nous
semble-t-il inacceptable et
juridiquement choquant ne craignez vous
pas monsieur le garde des sceaux de voir
le conseil constitutionnel
appliquez une jurisprudence restrictives
au droit d'amendement des parlementaires
dans le domaine fiscal
je vous pose la question
ce ministre bref nous sommes en présence
d'une révolution anti parlementaire
dans le domaine fiscal et j'y vois je
suis pas si le moins est adapté une
tutelle inacceptable du parlement où une
curatelle chez pas comme il faut dire je
m'adresse aux spécialistes mais j'aurai
l'occasion d'intervenir dans ce débat
qui n'a fait que commencer a lors de la
discussion générale
je vous remercie merci je présente un
couteau monsieur le ministre je ne vois
ni l'enfer ni la tutelle il a un
curatelle dans ce texte dont j'approuve
l'esprit qui vise effectivement à nous
doter de garde-fous pour contraindre le
législateur à tendre vers l'équilibré
des finances publiques
ceci étant dit ce texte
en mon cher collègue oui avant tout les
deux vallées ceux ci et les deux les
deux
ceci étant dit
ceci étant dit ce texte par le budget de
l'état de celui de la sécurité sociale
et collectivités locales ne sont pas
directement concernés ceci étant dit les
mesures qui seront prises les mesures
qui seront prises pour tendre vers
l'équilibré budgétaire ont déjà un
impact sur les collectivités locales
7 ces mesures ne seront soutenable pour
les collectivités locales les plus
pauvres qu'à partir du moment où une
réforme de la péréquation sérieuse sera
adopté le parlement y travaillent
l'assemblée le sénat les associations le
texte constitutionnel dit aujourd'hui
très peu de choses sur la péréquation
bisque de mémoire il est indiqué que les
lois de finance met en oeuvre des
mécanismes de péréquation ce qui est
quand même somme toute assez peu
contraignant est ce que nous pourrions
envisager dans le cadre de ce texte de
durcir un tout petit peu cet objectif
justement pour préparer le débat que
nous aurons en loi de finances à
l'automne
et pour nous assurer que les
collectivités locales seront en capacité
notamment les plus pauvres de suivre
l'état dans son effort budgétaire
madame des ego oui merci
mais si le président je suis garde des
sceaux je pense qu'avec les ces lois
cadres d'équilibré des finances
publiques ont créé en fait un instrument
juridique nouveau faut avoir une
conscience de ça avec l'objectif que
j'approuve bien évidemment et je pense
que c'est quand même un changement
profond d'où nos débats du cadre
national de nos finances publiques
moi je partage l'avis de françois baroin
toute la guerre qui a dit que en fait ça
c'est au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités avec cette affaire et je
pense vraiment moi je parlerais de
majorité moi je dirais comme particulier
je pense que toute majorité avec un tel
texte
nouvellement élu cette majorité elle
devra désormais prendre ses
responsabilités et prendre donc une
stratégie crédible en matière de
finances publiques
donc moi j'approuve tout à fait cet
élément là ce qui m'interroge ce qui me
pose problème c'est que dans les huit
premiers dans le texte qui est adoptée
par l'assemblée nationale il a été dit
que les lois cadres d'équilibré des
finances publiques détermine pour au
moins 3 années
alors ça ça me ça m'interroge je ne peux
pour au moins trois ans était pas dans
le texte initial
moi ça m'interroge beaucoup parce que
voyez-vous qu'on dise ça sur la nous
sommes dans une guerre qui n'a que ce
soit sur la durée du quinquennat aucun
problème si pas si on applique que votre
texte ce texte la part de la majorité de
l'international ça veut dire que
hambourg avant une majorité qui fait
d'abord trois ans et après elle va pas
pouvoir faire à seulement deux ans elle
va faire trois ans donc elle elle est
sur la période du quinquennat suivant de
normes
ça ça me dérange je me dis peut en tout
cas je je pense que ça mérite qu'on s'y
interroge voilà si c'est sur le
quinquennat et là on est dans la logique
de ce que viennent de dire françois
baroin qui a dit ça ça ça impacte
d'abord les gouvernements donc bon je
dis les majorités et donc qu'ils auront
donc une responsabilité nouvelle en la
matière il faut la prendre sur la durée
de leur mandature
moi j'avoue que ce trois ans ou moins me
paraît parce que moi ça me gênerait pas
qu'on fasse 3 ou 3 ans d'abord et après
on ferait deux ans pour le restant de la
du quinquennat mais voilà enfin moi je
demande simplement qu'on y réfléchisse
et c'est quelque chose qui n'était pas
dans le texte initial du gouvernement du
reste sur colombes à monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
oui j'ai d'abord j'ai bien conscience de
l'indignité qu'il y a modeste membre de
la commission des lois d'intervenir sur
un sujet où il ya ici
d'éminents spécialistes ceci dit je me
demande quand même si les médecins qui
ont nous ont conduits qui ont conduit
nos finances dans l'état où elles sont
sont les mieux qualifiés pour prescrire
dans les remèdes qui nous permettront
d'en sortir
alors je sais bien c'est la faute des
américains c'est la faute des grecs
c'est la faute de chez pas quoi bon moi
je constate que la politique c'est
conduire un pays et je constate l'état
dans lequel nous sommes personnellement
pour moi l'équipe va pour moi
l'equilibre où le déséquilibre
budgétaire c'est simplement un outil au
service d'une politique économique une
politique de l'emploi
c'est un but c'est pas un but en soi une
politique ne peut pas être défini a
priori mais en tenant compte des
circonstances tout ça c'est un débat de
fond
mais comme tout le monde quand semble à
peu près d'accord sur l'orthodoxie qui
nous a conduit dans un état où nous
sommes jeunes en débattrait pas plus
simplement je voudrais avoir quelques
éclaircissements sur la façon dont
fonctionne le dispositif que vous nous
proposez donc les lois cadres vont
s'imposer aux lois de finances et aux
lois donc là la sécurité sociale qu'est
ce qui va se passer
lorsqu'elle ne seront pas respectés
lorsque monde loi de règlement
s'apercevra que c'est pas ça que les
minimums les minima ont été dépassées ou
pas qu'est ce qui se passe alors nous
vous me dites que il ya des
compensations et la définition de ces
compensations et renvoyé à une loi
organique
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir quelques
précisions sur ces mécanismes france
tout cas quelques quelques idées parce
que je pense que vous en avez commencé
compensation vont-elles avoir lieu par
exemple si on constate si on constate
que le déficit est dû à un défaut de
rentrer une insuffisance de rentrées
fiscales
parce qu'on connaît une période une
période de ralentissement économique une
période de crise ne pas à l'abri de ça
loin de là qu'est ce qu'on fait on on
augmente les impôts on l'est pour
pouvoir boucler le déficit on fait quoi
voilà je veux dire que c'est enfin
disons vouloir régler ses problèmes
délicats qui sont des cadets de pilotage
de la machine économique à partir de loi
de finances voir dans la constitution
ça me paraît complètement à côté du
problème et même on cite régulièrement
les allemands etc
mais en allemagne ça ne marche pas ça
n'a pas marché
et ça marche de moins en moins suffit de
regarder les chiffres
alors donc est ce que c'est vraiment la
voie dans laquelle il faut aller
effectivement comme disait le rapporteur
général du budget la république c'est la
vertu mais la première vertu ce serait
peut-être celle des parlementaires et
celles des gouvernements de s'y tenir
et s'ils font des budgets de s'y tenir
c'est pas parce qu'on leur a mis dans la
constitution que ça changera grand chose
monsieur monsieur dassault ça vous ça
vous monsieur le président d'aso voilà
deux petites questions est ce qu'ils ont
considéré collectif budgétaire dont on
parle est un équilibre à 3% à 0 %
comparé les gains budgétaires et on
parle d'opération de communautés alors
voulons savoir si les 3 % sur 3 % 60
milliards de déficit et gamme
considérable 6 0 % par ferrer 0%
le diamant une chose que je ne vois pas
c'est on parle jamais du remboursement
de la dette qui tient 100 milliards
précis on était 15 milliards par an ça
ferait sens en forme aussi adepte va
peut-être quand même commencé alors on
ne parle jamais dit en gros sont là
est-ce qu'on va parler un jour est-ce
qu'on va rembourser la dette commençait
de rembourser on me dit que le rembourse
fécond et prendre on emprunte
immédiatement pour compenser et ça veut
dire que on ne change rien et on ne
compte en augmente la dette par ailleurs
donc comment est ce que on réduit la
dette qui continue à augmenter chaque
année
et puis y'a pas par exemple quelque
chose qui me plaît bien là dedans alors
le résultat me plaît parce que nick est
bizuté assez fondamentale on vit quelque
part que revote chaque année un maximum
de dépenses
j'aimerais bien que on commence tout de
suite par ça parce que je rappelle que
lorsqu'on veut ton le budget en novembre
va tam actions de dépenser que cette
dépense sont augmenté chaque année où
chaque chaque mois par le gouvernement
qui a inventé des solutions nouvelles
qui coûte plus cher et qu'on ne compense
évidemment pas par des recettes
donc si déjà on impose à tous les
pauvres parlementaires de ne pas faire
d'amendements qui ont montré les
dépenses sans avoir de recettes
j'aimerais bien que le gouvernement
aussi ce
des choses près aussi ses dispositions
pour lui est dans le mental chaque
chaque point chaque fois qu'ils avancent
quelque chose parce sinon que subvention
de cela et saluant ses dépenses et ses
recettes au sol montrent le déficit de
l'année
voilà merci de ses réponses merci de la
pertinence et d'abris était de vos
questions alors monsieur daudigny et
puis après on demande au garde et
remercie monsieur le président au
ministre une question précise relative
donc ou nouvelle loi d'équilibré en
matière sociale loi cadre des kits des
finances en matière sociale pour ce qui
est d'assurer sociale le rapport indique
bien que le champ couvert est plus large
que celui des lois de financement
puisqu'il correspond aux administrations
de sécurité sociale au sens de la
comptabilité nationale c'est à dire non
seulement les régimes obligatoires de
base de ski au réseau social mais aussi
l'assurance chômage et les régimes
complémentaires obligatoires de retraite
heures n'y at il pas dans ces
dispositions menace d'effacement du rôle
des partenaires sociaux
si des objectifs de dépenses sont fixés
ainsi de façon contraignante donc par
exemple à l'unedic
merci et alors monsieur le garde des
sceaux c'est le plongeon merci de bien
loin de la parole je suis naturellement
indigne de répondre à toutes les
questions que vous vous posez parce que
je n'ai pas votre science mais je vais
quand même essayer je vais quand même
essayer et d'apporter quelques éléments
de réponse peut-être avant de rentrer
dans les détails des questions rappeler
quelle est la finalité de cette réforme
je crois que monsieur baroin l'a fort
bien dit tout à l'heure il s'agit pas je
me reprendre l'expression de que madame
budget digne à utiliser tout à l'heure
c'est pas une opération de
parlementarisme rationalisé c'est bien
plus que cela
t'es pas de mental sera rationalisée
c'est entre les deux guerres les
théoriciens dire qu'ils échouent carré
de malberg et il voit quoi ils voient la
république parlementaire qui est
incapable de répondre
la montée des périls et essaye de
rationaliser le rôle du parlement
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il s'agit de
discipline et l'ensemble des pouvoirs
publics
et quelle est la discipline contenues
dans ce texte elle s'adresse d'abord et
peut-être avant tout aux gouvernements
personne de le plaindre dans cette
affaire ou alors mais c'est quand même
la vérité parce que c'est aussi le
gouvernement qui utilise cette technique
ou qu'il les laisse être utilisées donc
la discipline est les versions pour le
parlement c'est évident mais elle est
aussi pour le gouvernement et je crois
qu'il faut que l'on en est pleinement
conscience il s'agit tout simplement de
se doter
et je le dis pour ben brik des outils de
maîtrise des finances publiques dans la
durée et c'est important même à la
veille des élections
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
apprécié le début de l'intervention du
président cola c'est à dire qu'après
j'ai pu bien compris mais comme je le
connais bien je suis je suis sûr je suis
sûr que ce qui l'intéressait
comme toujours c'est le début de
l'intervention et il est je cite le
pailleur collin qui est dit ce qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui est bien ce qui
nous rassemble aujourd'hui et je suis
heureux que pendant que la édiles nous
rassemble c'est à dire tous quels que
soient nos options politiques c'est de
doter notre pays d'un str humant certes
de procédures d'instruments qui vont
nous permettre de juguler et les
déficits
alors est ce que c'est le bon moment
pour le bon moment il faut bien puisque
madame briques nous a rappelé que ce
n'était pas le bon moment
c'est vrai il ya eu un moment privilégié
certains 1998-2003 ans de croissance à
3%
c'était le moment où il aurait fallu
faire ce texte il n'a pas été fait et il
n'est jamais trop tard pour bien faire
même si c'est un peu plus même si c'est
un peu plus difficile
voilà vous avez tendu damas faut que je
vous le dise et c'est pour vous montrer
que j'ai écouté des toujours et je crois
que véritablement ce sujet est un sujet
d'importance et qu'il doit pouvoir nous
rassembler tous au delà des clivages
politiques on peut discuter des
modalités
cela est évident mais on ne peut pas
discuter
le principe même de cette autodiscipline
que peuvent s'imposer et les pouvoirs
publics
je veux dire à monsieur fourcade que
j'ai bien d'écouter ces questions tout
d'abord je veux leur assurer l'équilibré
des comptes des administrations
publiques recouvre bien les intérêts de
la dette sur la correction des écarts il
s'agit de s'inspirer du système mise en
oeuvre en allemagne avec un compte de
contrôle et une correction des écarts
l'année suivante où les années d'après
ce sera au législateur organique et d'or
des cdi je veux dire j'ai produit ce
colin donc remercie son sens du
rassemblement
même si après il a utilisé mais là
c'était probablement un moment de
faiblesse révolution anti parlementaire
en or ou non dont l'expression est trop
forte pour être vrai et est lui-même a
eu de la peine à la prononcer donc le
conseil de supprimer et de garder que
l'idée de rassemblement et s'agissant de
l'intervention de monsieur dassier qui
nous a interrogé sur la réforme de la
péréquation pense pas honnêtement
qu'opus tout mettre dans la constitution
alors je sais bien que dans certains
pays on peut trouver cela notamment des
états de l'aviation fédérale
mais la france est une république une et
indivisible
donc on n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes
relations entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
l'obligation pour les collectivités
locales d'établir leur budget en
équilibre en existe il ya pas besoin de
la mettre dans la constitution
c'est une disposition qui est légal ou
réglementaire et s'agissant de la
péréquation
un premier pas a été fait en mode
finances de 2001 et devraient être
précisées en loi de finances pour 2012
pourrait madame des ego et je crois que
la remarque
jégo a fait est intéressante mais quand
on dit au moins trois années ça
n'empêche pas du tout de faire une noix
de mandature c'est au moins trois années
c'est pas au plus trois années on peut
aller sans problème jusqu'à cinq ans
mais c'est au moins trois années est une
nouvelle majorité qui s'installe après
une élection présidentielle élections
législatives peut naturellement si elle
le souhaite aller au delà est fixé le
cap pour la durée et du vin du mandat du
quinquennat
ensuite monsieur que l'on bat nous a
expliqué que c'était ce qui avait mis le
feu qui essayaient de l'éteindre
eh bien c'est faux ah ouais c'est
complètement faux mais il ne sait aussi
c'est parce que rien n'a été fait rien
n'a été fait en 1998 quand il y avait
une forte croissance
oui c'est un peu dur mais c'est non mais
pas en 2007 non plus mais met pas en
2007 non plus toute politique est le
fruit d'une histoire et nous savons bien
mais vous avez choisi ce terrain là les
plaques s'est passé pas le terrain que
je préfère parce que je suis sûr que sur
ce sujet là on peut trouver les moyens
on peut trouver les moyens de rétablir
d'offrir ce public et c'est quand même
un objectif qu'on peut tous partager
quand l'état
et être est de plus en plus paralysé par
le poids de la dette dans son action le
souci qu'on peut tout savoir c'est bien
de libérer l'état en diminuant le poids
de la dette donc un des déficits
alors il ya très naturellement tout la
possibilité si la conjoncture est
mauvaise et de laisser les jouer les
stabilisateurs automatiques
lorsque cela est nécessaire et le texte
prêt permet tout à fait de le faire donc
tout doit être fait en cours d'année et
pour éviter que les normes d'évolution
des dépenses et des recettes ne soit pas
à respecter sinon on recourt à la
compensation et des écarts alors je me
dire à monsieur dassault que
d'équilibrer ses 1 0%
c'est 1 0% en équilibre c'est pas toi
c'est un déséquilibre maîtrisé 3 0 c'est
à déquilibre atteint donc c'est bien le
but et qui est poursuivi
ce remboursement de la dette si on
revient à l'équilibré fera petit à petit
diminuer le poids de la dette et je veux
dire à monsieur daudigny des j'aurai
retrouvé le papier que j'ai mélangé avec
les autres mais bon je veux bien y
arriver
voilà les plafonds de dépenses ne
s'impose pas à l'unedic ni au régime
complémentaire de retraite mais
uniquement au chant du plfss c'est à
dire aux régimes obligatoires de base ou
ne pouvait donc être rassurés on ne
porte pas atteinte au régime des petites
pelote pour les partenaires sociaux
voilà un monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs les précisons
que je suis en étant apportée à ce
moment même de la discussion
j'espère vous avoir convaincu aux
conséquences de soutenir ardemment ce
projet et de le voter
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le président qui voulait
intervenir sur la sur la période
triennale l'idée et j'aimerais que vous
nous confirmez monsieur le ministre
c'est que comme pour le programme de
stabilité on le vote chaque année mais
chaque année on ajoute une année
supplémentaire
c'est à dire qu on actualise ses trois
années qui glisse dans le temps ah mais
vous vous avez la parole monsieur le
garde des sceaux
merci beaucoup s'est présenté commission
des lois je veux dire poser d'articles
que c'est pas l'idée du texte il s'agit
pas d'un trio d'albi sont il va bien
falloir quand même faire coïncider ya le
programme de stabilité qu'on vote tous
les ans et il faut bien qu'il y ait
conformité entre le programme de
stabilité et la prévision régionales
c'est la trajectoire de finances
publiques en transmet dans le programme
de stabilité rick donne la parole et se
rappeler que c'est vous qui parlez
oui mais attendez alors bas le texte est
parfait mais il commence à voir quelques
imperfections par mois je peux sur n'est
pas d'accord sur les termes veuillez
m'excuser moi je ne sais plus mais moi
ça me dépasse complètement là je te
prends juste je pense que la question du
président arthuis je pense que la
question du président lui a dépassé sa
pensée
non non ce qui ne voulait rien à enlever
c'est à la personne à qui je souhaite à
faire mais je suis obligé de lui dire qu
en l'état ce n'est pas ce qui était
retenu dans l'assemblée nationale beh
et comme à se mettre d'accord parce que
la loi organique la loi organique de
poids quand même plus que la loi que la
constitution a écouté au jeu le
président vous permettez au moment où la
discussion va commencer oui on vient
avec le texte est une idée oui je veux
être appris qu'elle était l'idée du
gouvernement était contenu dans le texte
après avoir débat oui le débat on a bien
compris ça peut être l'adoption de la
formule de calais puisque nadal déjà
elle doit avoir deux sens dont débat
sera frais pour préciser le sens de la
formule a bien je vous remercie monsieur
le garde des sceaux mes chers collègues
et donc la forme
voilà je le répète pas et qu'il faut
qu'elles soient d'accord avec moi on
garde la formule mon charge le sens ça
fait un vote conforme et ça permet au
conseil constitutionnel de s'engouffrer
dans nos incohérences et je crois mais
ça c'est un autre sujet plus que lui sur
des lois ce que le temps est fini
e la source du droit était une source
nationale a voté la loi et on en a eu
encore un exemple aujourd'hui avec l
arrêt de la cour de luxembourg sur la
nationalité un principe de nationalité
et l'exclusivité nationale réservée aux
notaires c'est désormais terminé
ce qui était un vrai changement profond
mais nous en aurons d'autres changements
de ce type et je crois qu'elle est là la
globalisation des sources du droit qui a
fait l'objet d'ailleurs du cours de la
belle basse marty au collège de france
cette année deviendra est d'une grande
actualité pour les parlementaires et
nous invitera tous un peu de modestie
c'est la fin de cette audition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
à suivre le journal de 19h présenté ce
soir par michel grossiord bonne soirée à
tous